nander puts it through his legs it in William
nander William nander bust again scor a high
stick into the net is make it off everybody's
shoulder one rule everybody knows it scor what
a goal will your KNE Lander 24 seconds apart and
the lad lead and then Matthews puts it away here
they come again KNE Landers in over way scored
the goals come 30 seconds apart 3-1 leaps well
that is a ball Del lightning Matthews for jansson
gets away from Lin Morgan Riley to the fren and
neanders scores William neander bats it out of the
air through the ls of Bernier a minute three into
the second period and it's four nothing Tyson
Perry for Marner in front neander stores a goal
neander puts it through his liks it in this is
absolutely unbelievable by KNE Lander ring wide
for Matthews flying in his KNE Lander KNE Lander
to the N scores game winner William need Lander
backto back goals of the leaps at their 15th win
of the year off the draw streaking in neander a
backhander over the left shoulder of cin and it's
do nothing William neander with his fourth goal
in his last three games Riley back to the Captain
John tar is over the line with neander drag shoot
scores William neander with 98 seconds left in
the period and the Leafs have a four goal lead
again chance and probably an outside chance that
they'd move him that quickly into a playoff lineup
what a nice pretty feed from William needer and
John Taris makes it two to Nothing grabs the okok
product knock down KN Lander away maybe a break he
L her in four two for 88 in the leaps have five on
the night and that one bounced off off the arm
and underneath again they've done this with five
players by KNE L SC the and it's three this is one
team just being a little bit faster than the other
right now another one Puck race here and who gets
there first it's William neander who beats Walker
and then a beautiful finish on the back hand kner
attacks knocks it away he may have a break William
kner for the win scores KN Lander in overtime and
the Leafs hit 50 points on the season before the
TR deadline so it'll be interesting to see him
Lander in his for right second in and he is the
first goal of the game in back to back and neander
bounces it off the SC ofic neander in open ice but
neander steals it right back neander works his
way in scores William neander the steal and the
score and the leaes win it two to one in overtime
McCain for Brody BS for laford he with a full head
of steam turns s t drop set back for dander you C
the score yo on the feed from knan and the leavs
have the game's opening goal bro out comes tarus
neander on the Move William nander busting in
scores from an angle his second in as many games
and maybe as big as he's ever [Applause] scored
drop for nander he assisted on the power play
Go scor Beauty just like overtime last year for
William nander he sees the middle taken away gets
it to the outside uses his Edge as well and gets
it around gson one more game on lead extended
road trip to start great move knee lers in to
the middle drops toar scores it's a beauty for
joh tamarus on the kner seter and he puts it
exactly where he needed to it over the glove
between the glove and the ear the goal tender
neander hit back the back hand pass from the score
Morgan Riley has struck again been around a long
time gets caught HCK watching he's staring right
at William Mander he's got no idea that his guy
slipped in behind them brilliant feet and goal
Matthews throws out ah hit Knocked Down Bruce
Puck goes a kneel rning it scores what a move
by William neander a power play go it's one
nothing to ronal highy waiting for back around
the knee Lander Cent what a pass TOA scores oh
my goodness what a pass he tied himself into
a pretzel got hammered and then put it right
on a platter for John Taris now it's neander the
other way he's got tarus with him neander tries
and scores William V ler puts an exclamation
point and a brilliant week in Stockholm drops
it back to nean neander winds in still has a
neander it backr shoot score Austin Matthews
with a power play coming gives the Le a one
nothing lead regains control of it on this
near Side William neander scores what a shot top
corner neander with his head up the whole time and
just right over the shoulder gender down in that
technique to try to take away the bottom but the
one thing that's open is exactly where neander
put it that's only about 3 in of open space